how's it going there citizens of the reject
nation that is I channeled back once again
for for a how have you not seen this movie
reaction we are going back for another Disney
classic and animated Disney classic from the
the early 2000s and that is Lilo and Stitch
I am very excited to finally be catching up
with this but when you're done leaving that
comment about how have you not seen this movie
already John I don't believe you go ahead
and hit that like button uh helps us out very
much over here let's YouTube know what's good
and what you like to see as well hit that
notification Bell and subscription button
to get notified whenever one of these reactions
or something else that might pique your interest
pops up here on the channel as always as well
if you want to get the full experience with
me sync up with your own copy of Lilo and
Stitch and watch alongside me for the full
hour and 28 minutes come on over to our patreon
page patreon.com the real rejects we also
have tons of other shows and movies over there
with reaction High lights as well as watch
alongs included it's a lot of fun come check
it out and if you want to support the channel
and get some fresh drip in the process go
on over to our Shop zeroedition.com store
got a lot of cool designs over there including
a brand new who influences the influencers
T-shirt Greg came up with it's a sweet design
I'm jealous and hey without further Ado let's
go to the beach it's time for Lilo and Stitch
I'm excited it's you know it's still winter
but yeah it's summer in our hearts right let's
do this
love when they do something neat with the
Disney logo lead scientists of Galaxy defense
Industries you stand before this Council
experimentation that's a pretty Grim charge
for her we believe you
you're making clones on kamino what you see
before you is the first of a new species I
call it adorable merchandise or experiment
626. he is bulletproof fireproof and can think
fast
he's only instinct to destroy everything he
touches you had me up until the end there
I like that he barfs out little nuts and bolts
and things idiot scientist under arrest
[Music] of course you do cool like I wasn't
quite expecting this part I know we're probably
not going to spend much time here but like
this is a cool world the council has banished
you to Exile on a desert asteroid these guns
are locked onto your genetic signature they
won't shoot anyone but you
damn Captain veggie is on duty yeah secure
the South [Laughter] ever seen someone shoved
all the way inside a gun before does this
uh look infected to you
wow a nomadic colony of sorts traversing the
Galaxy
I feel like you should have calibrated your
smart guns to count account for something
like this
like this sort of gooey texture of their lasers
too
what was that I don't think he's on the ship
anymore confirmed he's taken a police cruiser
nice dude GTA Stitch going hard out here [Music]
yeah
that's it we've got it we've got it uh-oh
do not engage
now you're in for a Hawaiian vacation of a
lifetime you're still in hyperspace where
will he exit section zero zero five area 51.
area 51. what is that water most of the planet
is covered in it he won't survive and move
to his molecular density is too great he'll
drown [Music] no [Laughter] of course Earth
is a protected Wildlife Reserve yeah we've
been using it to rebuild the mosquito population
which need remind you is an endangered species
can we not simply destroy the island no crazy
head the the mosquitoes food of choice primitive
humanoid life oh if you master but they're
very delicate in fact every time an asteroid
strikes their Planet they have to begin life
all over oh my God this is taking me back
whoo then Mr pleately would you send for his
extraction does he have a brother close grandmother
perhaps
the the scientist six to six will not come
easily maybe a direct hit from plasma cannon
might stun him long enough to plasma cannon
granted do we have a bargain dang hmm but
it's a delicate Planet who's gonna control
him you will yes of course you will on what
Poor Pitiful defenseless planet has my monstrosity
been Unleashed
good transition don't worry Earth is prepared
for this
sandwich fish
oh little one
let's go Alan Silvestri made some classic
scores over the years I love a good opening
title sequence
some aloe vera on you my guy
based on an idea by Chris Sanders I like that
the way they phrase that just makes it sound
like he was like ah ah like an alien in Hawaii
and then they'd created everything else based
off of that
hey
wow why are you all wet every Thursday I take
Pudge the fish a peanut butter sandwich fudge
is a fish he sounds so tired of this
[Music]
[__] friends don't let friends become
cannibals
[Applause] oh we should call your sister no
I'll be good I just want to dance I practice
oh little ones don't worry you'll be a world-class
dancer in no time
are you gonna let her head is too big so I
pretend the bug Light eggs in her ears and
she's upset because she only has a few more
days too oh I'll hang out with you childhood
me would be about that this is already pulling
in my heart's drinks
uh oh that guy's gonna come back God the animation's
Beautiful [Music]
Heartbreak Hotel
[Music]
oh I'm gonna stop you in the blender push
puree then bake you into a pie and feed it
to the social worker and when he says this
is great what's your secret I'm gonna say
love
get safe [Music] oh damn body and in question
yes I'm Nani nice to meet you mister bubbles
that's a string yes I know are you going to
invite me in Nani do you have the meats Nani
what cup what kind of social worker is this
guy looks like he works for a Crime Boss or
like he is the crime Buzz hey so lemonade
do you often leave your sister home alone
no never oh God ah we had to run to the store
to get some
cleaning supplies
special classification did you ever kill anyone
we're getting off the subject
four groups and up both ways before crossing
the street and take long naps and get disciplined
she disciplines me real good sometimes five
times a day
hahaha oh [Music] practical voodoo there's
there's an edge on the writing of this that
I very much enjoy my friends need to be punished
call an exorcist after all this in case you're
wondering this did not go well [Laughter]
boy oh no no no no no he's gonna be back in
there like instantaneously
the pizza box oven door
that's great do you want to be taken away
answer me no no you don't understand [Music]
you're such a pain why do you sell me by a
rabbit instead I don't like because it's sticky
like you oh [Music] everyone rings around
you logically [Music]
you and me both sisters we're a broken family
aren't we maybe a little oh [Music] shouldn't
have yelled at you we're sisters it's our
job yeah well from now on I like you better
as a sister than a mom oh and you like me
better as a sister than a rabbit right yes
yes I do that is a Nuance man
yes you capture the real life
real people
nice timing [Music]
I need someone to be my friend someone who
won't run away
the nicest Angel you
great timing great great transition they just
got the dearest little girl to play Lilo damn
it Disney crying already we're not 10 minutes
into this
You Can't Kill Them All
a
truck from Mad Max over here
witness me
30. you
know do we have a lobster door no we have
a dog door we are getting a dog we are taking
home the cast of Oliver and Company hello
are there any aminals in here oh no this is
your turtle in the back [Music] yeah you're
clever
where do those go oh
wow all of our dogs are adoptable except that
one [Laughter] does it have to be this dog
yes he's good I can tell his name is Stitch
oh no that's not a real name it's a dog name
oh that was sweet
that good why don't you run
I'm coming
stay out of the roads okay is that the giant
spider Invasion or something or tarantula
I love when they do that they put some kind
of old movie or stock footage on screen
yeah
ouch mean
he's loose his destructive programming is
taking effect he will be irresistibly drawn
to large cities where he will back up sewers
reverse street signs and steal everyone's
left shoe no not the left shoe he's already
committed Grand Theft big wheel
God I love the blending of Animation in this
I feel like this was it at like a Nexus point
in the early 2000s where you got like very
classical live on an island with no large
cities
nice with no large cities Great for an alien
invasion but yeah it's the blending of like
classical art styles and the Really crisp
character animations the occasional computer
animation beautiful oh
ouch
whoa no what you gotta learn some dog if you're
gonna blend in my guy
cool oh here we go
nice [Applause] oh no
you sure it's a dog he used to be a collie
before he got ran over yum cheese oh
egg [Laughter]
hahaha you're not doing anything David I told
you I can't I oh she likes her butt and fancy
hair I know I have a diary you do have good
hair my guy and I'm sure your butt is is just
as firm and and pert
[Music] um
whole head in the mouth
is that your dog ah all is well please go
about your business I'm okay your head looks
swollen actually she's just ugly
yeah this is not working out no
the manager's a vampire and he wanted me to
join his Legion of the undead
[Laughter] [Music] [Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter] he's obviously mutated from something
else we have to take him back whoa what about
a battle you haven't been here that long
means family oh
there's a theme nobody gets left behind or
forgotten ah I love their relationship down
you don't touch this don't ever touch it oh
no is that Mom and Dad oh covering from surgery
[Music] period of course
make something for a change
it's a little sit here San Francisco it's
it's San Francisco [Laughter] foreign
[Music]
goodness gracious me they're feasting on you
my dude I never gave him a greater purpose
what must it be like to have nothing not even
memories to visit I guess you got to create
your own The Ugly Duckling see he's sad because
he [Music] always breaks my heart his family
hears him crying and they find him then the
ugly duckling is happy because he knows where
he belongs oh you're the ugly duckling you're
both the ugly duckling look
[Music] [Laughter]
are there like Hollow Chambers in there despite
his amazing density you lost I just quit that
then a child
so sorry about that what is that thing that's
my puppy thus far you have been adrift in
the sheltered Harbor of my patients new job
model citizen good day
my man's got bars
[Music] he
hold it like this put your fingers here see
now you try
shred Stitch but I just hide Teddy in the
tour season in
[Music] that is that is that is virtuosic
play oh we might have something good now kiss
him ugh I'm sure Elvis had his bad days too
oh goodness actually I do think we have an
opening really okay
oh that would be so great you have no idea
how badly I need this oh no oh no [Music]
no no no bad bad bad
[Music] times the fun saver
[Applause] it's all going so difficult for
a guy in his ice cream
oh come back not Pamela Anderson we can talk
about this hey I might not be a doctor but
I know that there's no better cure for a sour
face than a couple of boards and some Choice
waves what do you think that is a bar
oh
you're about to find a new passion foreign
you can do it
oh
yeah not bad
killing it Nani whoa good catch never surfed
but this is making me want to I used to skateboard
which are totally the same
[Music] I want to be built into a sand castle
[Music] oh
I love the way they're capturing the water
too the below surface shots through the waves
like ah
thank you
oh you guys
oh
[Music] oh Jeeps this morning bigger oh [Music]
kicked him in the head no
whoa
damn
oh
he's unconscious but I think he's alive
do some emergency CPR oh okay he's fine this
isn't what it looks like I know you're trying
Nadi but you need to think about what's best
for Lilo you just don't have that removes
you from the picture no I really believe they
had a chance then you came along
oh
fix this you better fix this
yeah that's us before it was rainy and they
went for a drive oh no Disney no what happened
to yours I hear you cry at night do you dream
about them you dream about the torturous laboratory
process your family's little now but if you
want you could be part of it you could be
our baby then we'd raise you to be good oh
family means nobody gets left behind or forgotten
how could you not I for everyone that leaves
oh
lost oh
[Music] ugh my heart
I mean you come out here this could be your
chance to redeem yourself Captain gun too
how soon will you be prepared to leave immediately
I thought you'd never ask Donald Trump yes
that's it come quietly or waiting waiting
oh
don't have one maybe I could you're built
to destroy you can never belong nurture come
on nurture I think I found you a job you what
old man kuakini storm but we gotta hurry I'm
gonna be right back lock the door and don't
answer it for anyone okay not even the social
worker guy oh David I owe you one that's okay
we'll call it even come on you too oh my yes
yep yep right on time
hound dog rocking all the time you know you
didn't originally write that song though put
you back together again you taller and not
so fluffy I like fluffy I do too you could
do is a makeover I tried to give you my good
looks but let's face it something went wrong
no no oh teamwork [Music]
that is a toiletries kit what have you done
to the girl
the Bulls don't call Bubbles about this
punch buggy that's where that came from everything's
under control Lilo who was that oh good my
dog down the chainsaw don't hang yes the the
Stitch Chainsaw Massacre
oh boy oh boy oh boy
you won't be disappointed I'll show up early
to help with the morning
yeah don't turn left yep no no oh
boy oh boy oh boy please don't do this you
know I have no choice no
no that it needs to be
no seems clear to me that you need her a lot
more than she needs you
ouch oh no
you're one of them oh
surprise of course surprise [__]
there you go all buckled up for the trip
that almost sounded like not on ball Mountain
for a second whoa oh my God what Lilo also
the existence of extraterrestrial life but
but also
damn it you're under arrest Freedom Is Right
Freedom Is Right bring her back oh we can't
do that uh-huh that would be misuse of Galactic
resources dude Ohana means family yep nobody
gets left behind
after all you put me through you expect me
to help you just like that
fine what exactly are we doing rescue we're
gonna get Leela hey do it team [Music] [Laughter]
nice little Jaws tribute [Music]
me I thought you'd like to know that the little
Abomination is
mooning us she must already know they called
why are we I was gonna say you are not as
aerodynamic you're doing a pretty decent job
of evading but still oh
wow [Music]
wow get off my ship oh damn
don't leave me okay okay oh so Earnest Frogger
oh oh no what is your plan [Music]
sweet abomination
nice use of chemistry [Music]
nobody's just left behind ah YouTube you crazy
kids bubbles is definitely gonna understand
after this I am retiring you captain ouch
none of this stitch them if it wasn't for
Stitch huh
yes let's just say goodbye yes yes
I love her reactions in that moment who are
you this is my family family
for good
still good absolutely model citizen bubbles
you take them you're stealing and I will sue
you from across the Galaxy all about rules
you look familiar periods are all about CIA
Roswell 1973. yes a sentence that shall be
henceforth served out here on Earth yes ma'am
on on a earth don't let those two get on my
ship are they exiled too yeah I guess they
are what a cool looking ship too CIA former
Save the Planet once convinced an alien race
that mosquitoes were an endangered species
foreign [Music]
damn you just got Distortion built in to your
biology yes oh nice digs
[Music] you surf day
that looks like quite a cake oh and even bubbles
came
oh
cool I love little Jetsons noises
yes I have vengeance
how lovely oh it went visited Elvis's Estates
okay he went to Graceland yeah oh how lovely
man that was so nice and I love too that you've
got you've got all this music and it's not
a musical but there is still you know music
present throughout and and you know as a sort
of part of the movie's identity so great
love these family photos too this is great
nice nice use of that Motif for the ending
credits here just a hawk it's Crush it's a
little crush ah how lovely yes oh I love it
I love that they yeah they cut him out they
made a cutout to put someone in the picture
that's that's awesome oh oh my friends oh
that was such a delight
oh man that was so delightful I really wish
I had gotten to see that in the theaters when
I was a kid and I hope that somebody screens
it you know at some point coming up because
I would love to see some of this artwork like
it's funny this movie was doing so many things
but this really pulled me in and I could see
why it you know it has kind of stood the test
of time as one of their Classics I mean I
feel like they spun a lot of other stuff out
of this obviously not that franchising something
makes it good but um this is yeah A really
lovely convergence of so many different things
and I was very dazzled by it because I feel
like you know again these movies are in some
ways very Compact and very straightforward
and some it's funny going back to some of
these Disney movies that I missed I feel like
some of them uh have fallen into a category
where I'm like okay that was really fun maybe
a little slight but fun like you know kind
of throws you right into things whereas this
was one of the examples of one that feels
like very full and well-rounded and rich with
a bunch of different things and it's just
done so with such efficiency but also such
compassion that yeah it just feels like kind
of the perfect package like I really love
this like I I'd be curious to see in a few
days time how I'm feeling but yeah like this
is one that even seeing it now I feel like
there's so much to appreciate and I loved
yeah just the juxtaposition like the blending
of these two flavors you know you start out
with this like you know wild sort of fun like
not pulse pounding exactly but you know you're
starting out with like a Sci-Fi fugitive situation
where you have this like bioengineered destruction
machine in 626 and the ensuing Manhunt as
he escapes uh their uh you know capture uh
but then you know pretty soon I I think they
proportioned things out really nicely because
that could have been in danger of feeling
like it was from a different movie or something
like that but I think that or or it could
have felt random I guess you know being that
he crashed lands in Hawaii this movie has
a certain amount of that culture imbued into
it and especially like you know the the convergence
of Hawaiian culture with American culture
I think specifically and sort of it paints
it it puts it it's sort of an interesting
point in time and and place and yeah like
I feel like having the uh uh sci-fi element
could just feel like any old random thing
but it felt really natural here and it felt
like a really fun way of you know creating
a universe that you could expand on not that
again franchising is like the the sign of
quality but like yeah it made this engrossing
little world and then managed to engross me
again with just like actual real life problems
and endearing characters and yeah I mean I
really loved Lilo and I loved Nani and I loved
their relationship with each other and I thought
they did a nice job of making something that
was like thrilling and fun and even though
it's not a musical it still has music throughout
and music is an important part of it and uh
and yeah like you know it manages I think
to draw a pretty nuanced picture of a struggling
family like like when they have that moment
where she addresses that whole idea that I
like you better when as my sister than as
my mom and and you know I like you better
as my sister than as my daughter or whatever
that was like that's it's such a I mean it's
like it's a it's a hard Bittersweet thing
and the movie doesn't ever shy away from stuff
like that and even if Cobra Bubbles is like
a pretty funny unlikely character even that
is is sort of perfect like you can see how
he might have some level of compassion you
can also see why he wouldn't be completely
why you would have any patience at all for
them adopting this alien um it's it's like
it's it's goofy even in a way but in a way
that I really really appreciated and had a
lot of fun with and I think everybody really
honed in perfectly on and I mean like again
the the the voice acting alone I thought was
really great uh Lilo like she's so endearing
and and such a a great little rascal because
I think it would be easy for that character
to become annoying and I never was I I was
only ever as annoyed with her as you know
like Nani was supposed to be or something
like that and vice versa like I think they
did really nicely to flesh these characters
out and to make them both expressive within
the animation but also just within the drama
at hand and and drawing these situations that
again lend themselves to hijinks when stitches
around and when those things are happening
but also lend themselves to real life precarious
situations you know again that whole thing
where she goes home on her own after dance
class locks her sister are out and then the
social worker shows up in the midst of just
like a bad moment like that could have easily
become Halloween ends um but yeah just like
the the again deafness at which they wove
between the two and having also the uh what
are their names I have the IMDb pulled up
here uh Jumba and and pleakly which Kevin
McDonald getting some Kids in the Hall love
in there and I know I've heard uh uh David
Ogden steyer's voice before um but yeah like
having them as you know these sort of the
the essentially like the buddy cop Duos chasing
them and trying to apprehend them and the
you know further you know supporting characters
of the Galactic Federation and all that stuff
like I really enjoyed the you know sort of
flavors of other movies that that lent whether
it kept reminding me of like a gross point
blank even though it's not like a one-to-one
comparison but how you have like um Hank Azaria
and uh oh I forget the other actor's name
he's got the mustache uh you know like they're
kind constantly bumping into these Hitmen
and they're constantly like kind of at odds
and they're all aware of each other you know
it was fun because you get to watch I thought
they did a really nice job of having it be
yeah like Stitch is mostly out for himself
for a while he's just trying to evade these
two and Destroy as much as he can but then
they introduce a kind of interesting like
that I I like the fact that you have this
this mad genius scientist guy also being like
he's like kind of sympathetic in a way like
he he has like created I don't know what what
it kind of the ethics of what you know created
Stitch are exactly but you know it doesn't
seemed like a deplorable character in his
uh depths uh not that's exactly the right
way to put that but you know uh and having
you know completely be so uh sort of Plucky
and you know buy the book you know like they're
a good Odd Couple but also they're like a
good couple to observe Stitch and I love the
whole thing about the mosquitoes and like
you know uh Cobra convincing them you know
saving Earth by basically convincing them
that this is some kind of nature preserved
for mosquitoes um especially you know out
here when uh summertime hits you know like
the mosquito struggle is real so I guess if
that was the cost thank you um but yeah having
it be that they go to this Nature Preserve
so for their purposes there's some reason
to preserve it and for our purposes of course
you know we would like it not to be completely
destroyed or terraformed or obliterated or
whatever um but yeah like that draws like
the right amount of stakes and then it's fun
to watch is yeah you know Lilo you know goes
through the process again of opening up to
somebody and having a bond with a friend and
and maybe trusting that they won't just leave
and even that like like that was I think again
there's that Meme of like you know if you're
a parent in a Disney movie you know like dude
you're you're probably dead already like you
know if you've made it to part way through
the movie even well done um but yeah like
this does address again some difficult walks
of life to deal with and certain you know
ways in which people have to grow up earlier
than they should maybe that anyone should
have to and I thought they tempered that nicely
with her growth and and just you know learning
to uh understand better what the scope of
her family is and how to take care of them
and everybody's sort of checking back in on
the Ohana theme that family means nobody gets
left behind and nobody gets forgotten yeah
I love that she invokes that at first as sort
of like a card to pull to get what she wants
but you know that really does get tested and
tempered over the course of the movie and
yeah going back to that point from before
I love that you have the two guys in a position
to observe Stitch because then that brings
up this other conversation uh about you know
like he doesn't really have any sort of like
greater purpose that I imbued him with and
so they kind of let this sort of again there
are so many like little subplots happening
Below in between the A and B plot of the movie
plots of the movie um but I love that too
that like it allows for Stitch's growth as
a being as a creature you know as this sort
of halfway like he's feral at first you know
he seems very creature-like and then as the
movie goes he learns to speak uh English and
everybody kind of speaks English except it
seems like Stitch also is speaking some other
alien language that's maybe his own or whatever
but yeah like over the course of the movie
he learns to better communicate and clearly
has much better of a grip on it than he lets
on it first or or after a while but yeah just
introducing this idea of what level of nature
is at work here and what level of nurture
could maybe you know give him he's a new creature
like as much as he is like a threat and and
you know Adept at destruction at the same
time he's just like a new life form so like
maybe he deserves a shot and maybe he can
grow to maybe not just want to destroy everything
and I think the way that they realize that
in the story and the way that they uh spilled
those odds over back and forth between Lilo
and Stitch like you know Lilo has to not you
know uh wreak havoc on the world around her
inadvertently through just losing herself
in Joy or uh or despair or whatever and it's
uh more Primal way stitch has to do the same
thing and so yeah like the I thought they
Blended nicely the real Stakes of you know
like the sister needing to have a job needing
to support them maybe the social worker is
going to separate them and you know everybody
seems to be on or they seem to be on really
thin ice with just everybody around like yeah
you know it was it was a nice set of plates
that they managed to spin because it feels
like you know sort of a full fantasy sci-fi
Adventure you know again it's it's and and
that is like drawing I think in a very nice
way like you know these 2000 zero Disney movies
and watching The Emperor's New Groove certainly
uh had this effect where it's like you can
tell this is Disney for a slightly different
era it's a little more Rye it's a little more
Punchy and quippy and the jokes and the humor
um but this I thought I mean you know for
good reason uh Emperor's New Groove is like
a very quippy movie it's you know a very much
a comedy and this I thought you know had just
the right amount of that and just the right
amount of that for me as if you were borrowing
from uh just you know sci-fi in general and
sci-fi Adventure fantasy movies and things
like that and so you know part of it feels
like it sort of skews even though like this
would be fun I think for you know the family
what you think of when you think of a family
movie but also you know it skews kind of a
little bit older too for you know fans particularly
of that Vibe and aesthetic and yeah like in
a way this almost reminded me a little bit
of Avatar because it's like you have this
alien race it's like kind of like a reverse
Avatar somehow it's like you have this alien
race and you know they send one of their people
else they send some people to Earth to elsewhere
and then you know you sort of learn that uh
terrain and you see what that ecosystem is
like and what the experience is of living
in that world and it's like here it's you
have the surf scenes and things like that
you're spending time in town and you're you're
sitting around you know at the table while
you know Nani's doing her weight service and
all that stuff and and then we're you know
back underwater and the way they captured
water like the animation in this movie I thought
was really cool too across the board and there
were moments where I was like okay there's
a bit of us what appears to be a bit of a
CG effect um you know for certain of the more
sci-fi elements and then you have the very
crisp you know uh uh sort of hero character
animations but like I I loved how much of
this felt like really tangible artwork on
screen uh so much of it you know was watercolors
and things like that which you know I I I
used to paint hard to admit but I used to
paint uh you know I I I used to love painting
in watercolor and I love seeing just the way
they Blended all that you know like those
more tangible feeling painting like uh you
know backdrops and establishing shots and
settings and things like that I don't know
it's just like a really a lively combination
of visual Styles and yeah especially when
they're in the water and the way that they
you know depict the camera so to speak you
know kind of being at surface level or at
least you know the eye whatever we're seeing
through our vision is sort of at surface level
so it you know like there's a lot that goes
into the perspective of that and you know
making that feel uh like transportive you
know to the ocean and it's funny like seeing
something like Avatar recently that is so
you know again photo real or is that you can
have something like this that if you watch
it on a big enough TV at moments you're like
wow you know like where you really are sort
of flying through space or we're you know
taking a deep dive underwater or falling off
the surfboard or whatever and this made me
uh nostalgic for my uh you know I never surfed
but you know because I was interested in skateboarding
I was also tangentially interested in Surf
life so uh yeah you know it's nice it's fun
uh and two I mean like I loved even the little
other motifs they had uh they're you know
you get like the Elvis music which you know
even that was kind of a neat nod to just other
Realms of Cinema because yeah I mean Elvis
made a ton of like beach movies and and you
know I I I'm not like necessarily know if
all of them are in Hawaii but I I'm sure at
least one or a few of them are and uh you
know I just thought that was kind of like
a neat aspect uh uh you know say what you
will about Elvis you know I thought that was
kind of just like a neat aspect of just yeah
like the life and the culture and especially
just like what these characters is doing you
know with their time and their passion and
I love that she's got like her wall of photos
and the little dolls that she creates and
and yeah just like you know it shows you who
the characters are through little things like
that it makes him feel more alive uh little
flourishes I like I love the little movie
on the TV and the window and stuff like that
like this feels like a A really lovely piece
of artwork and uh yeah it just manages to
do all the things that it's doing so naturally
that none of it feels like it's you know I
don't know you're just not thinking about
like the mechanics of the script or the structure
or anything like that I think they managed
to depict A really lovely uh and touching
mess and you know this yeah this this tale
of this broken little family who gets a little
bit bigger and maybe a little bit stronger
and a little bit more assured in just you
know what their unique Harmony is and can
be and I think that's lovely and I think yeah
again like making this maybe not exactly a
musical but a medley and a sort of review
of sorts uh was really nice and just yeah
like feeling like uh through very practical
means like you're exploring the island and
getting a little taste of you know each part
of life here and what there is to do uh David
too I thought you know while the love you
know the romantic story of him wanting to
date Nani isn't like super duper in uh the
foreground or anything like that like I thought
he was quite Charming a nice addition I ship
them I'm happy if he becomes uncle or brother-in-law
or whatever that is um and yeah just like
this was a really nice array of characters
a lot of really tender moments I mean this
made me cry multiple times like this was super
fun it made me laugh um and God the the use
of that ugly duckling like that page and the
way they animated it here too it's got that
same quality just like the way that duck looks
so perturbed and and lost and sad and just
like I'm lost uh like it always hits me in
the fields you know and and yeah I think they
made it like a really nice ugly duckling story
out of the tale of the both of them but also
you can really kind of apply it to a lot of
what characters are going through in this
because you know in associating with each
other they're all being alienated from the
norm of society and they're all sort of searching
for the place that they fit the most and I
like that by the end you know even the status
quo at least of the aliens learns to you know
open them so elves up and I love that loophole
of like they're all about the rules and since
you got stitched from the pound and you have
a legal document that says you paid whatever
two dollars for him then hey we gotta abide
by that we'll check in once in a while you
know uh that's just yeah it was super lovely
Ving Rhames too as bubbles like I loved that
I love the reveal of that I should have known
he was basically one of the Men in Black at
that point in time and I feel like this is
uh this would have been there's a little bit
of Men In Black in the DNA of this I mean
you know there's uh certainly the aliens feel
like they could easily fit into that Universe
just as a whole and uh you know Stitch wouldn't
be out of place in that universe so maybe
head Cannon they're the same and maybe Ving
Rhames is just one of the actual Men In Black
even though he says he's CIA it's fine um
but yeah like this was so lovely I loved all
the design work and stuff like that uh you
know you even got your Chase sequence in there
like there's this so much and again it never
feels like it's too fast or or you know too
slight or anything like that and every frame
all the artwork is just so rich like hell
yeah man like this going back to each of these
movies is always fun and interesting because
you never know and there's also a little bit
of pressure because you never know how you're
gonna feel and you know there's also there's
just that idea that like I don't wanna I've
heard this is great it's Timeless it's listed
the test of time I hope I like it as much
as everybody else does I hope I see what everybody
else sees in it and this is one where I feel
like I really definitely did and uh yeah I
am coming out of this experience just in the
Here and Now with you know a warm heart and
also just like the the urge to put this on
again like the great thing is like this movie
is really touching and it doesn't shy away
from the hard things or the Bittersweet things
or the sad things that lets you sit with the
emotion I love when uh what is that Tia Carrera
uh I love when Nani sings to Lilo in there
like that's a really sweet moment and like
the way in which yeah like they depict again
like the struggle to keep it together when
you're driving each other up a wall because
you're both kind of having your own reactions
to a harsh situation um but yeah like the
the way they got you to the point where you're
like man there's no coming back like this
All Is Lost and then the way they resolve
everything by the end was just like really
well thought out really satisfying uh loved
just the the esoteric little uh population
of people poor ice cream guy um just yeah
just like everything got a little kiss of
personality and TLC and I would you know just
as soon as yeah like recommend this to somebody
as like a quality film as I would put it on
just to kind of be inside of its Vibe and
all that and I hope that the extended media
from this is good is it you know maintains
a certain quality because uh you know like
this seems like one of those ones that's really
special and I hope uh I don't know it just
made me miss this kind of Animation you know
it made me miss uh the the drawn animation
style where even if it is assisted with computers
you can tell that yes like this is pieces
of Art and this is yeah some of this is like
a big watercolor painting that they then animated
on top of like you know like this is a wonderful
tradition of Cinema and then I think of stuff
like Strange World which I really want to
see uh and I feel bad because I'm like I love
when they do sci-fi stuff like this not the
strange world is necessarily the exact same
kind of movie as this or is aiming for the
feels that this is aiming for but like this
was such a cool convergence of things that
I love so anyway I feel like I have probably
talked your ear off long enough if you've
made it to this point which if you did thank
you so much because uh yeah I don't know I
love dishing on these movies and I love getting
to check them out and uh yeah I thought this
was a blast uh and I cannot wait to watch
it again so leave me your thoughts leave me
anything I missed talking about or anything
you want to point out to me any trivia any
other movies from this era I should check
out there are at least a couple other ones
I probably haven't seen you know try your
luck you never know uh yeah much love to you
guys and hey before we end this thing off
let's do a patreon
Chase Gardener my Demon Slayer dude among
many other fandoms we have shared over time
I'm taking a gamble on this one and hoping
that maybe this movie would be up your alley
and maybe you'll be like sweet a Lilo and
Stitch shout out well well let's let's shout
out but everyone was doing this for us that's
the that's the hook no that cannot be the
hook of this Shadow I'm so sorry that would
be so annoying to listen to prolonged not
that this isn't but uh dude Chase thank you
so much for just being here for so long and
for you know really just continuing to bring
such enthusiasm you crash landed in our little
ecosystem our little mosquito Sanctuary out
here the reject nation and you're always good
at bringing me the hype and I hope that in
2023 I I hope someone is bringing you the
hype maybe even like if you had like an actual
hype guy following you around like a hype
man that would be the coolest but even just
you know people supporting you and making
you feel uh loved and as though you can achieve
your aspirations your goals your hopes and
and Beyond that's I mean we should all be
so lucky man so I hope that's going on for
you and I am just glad to have you as part
of our little rejection here it's always nice
getting to shout you out every month and remembering
that like damn somewhere out there that chase
Gardener is walking around being a generous
emmer effort and uh and and it deserves to
be known so thanks buddy I hope you're having
a good year and uh we'll chat soon much love
and uh yeah as always cheers [Music]